hey guys I'm Jess McDonald today is
October the third and I got five of the
biggest stories of the whole gaming week
ready to go for you so let's get into it
sunset overdrive is a totally new gaming
experience according to developer
insomniac games head of community James
Stevenson said that no one has made any
sort of game like sunset overdrive
before while Stephenson said that the
game takes inspiration from other games
like jet set radio Tony Hawk and peggle
among other things he explains we wear
it on our sleeve we're not trying to
pinch anything we're trying to show our
respect for a lot of that stuff like I
said what we made ultimately feels very
different to everything else you've ever
played so while it was certainly
inspired by all those things we've
certainly not pinched or ripped anyone
else off a bunch of Destiny players
suffering a bug also happen to find a
bunch of content that it was actually in
the game certain people who experience
the bug which lock them out of the tower
post of YouTube videos which Illustrated
several new and locked areas appearing
on the map it turns out this stuff is
dlc although according to bungee none of
it is finished and you will still need
to wait until at least December for the
launch of the first expansion pack in
the dark below this week microsoft
announced windows 10 can rattling users
by skipping nine but comforting those
who hated aids microsoft has promised to
abandon the unpopular metro tile
interface from eight and of explain
their jump over 9 into 10 by saying that
this is going to be the last major
update intending to follow this up with
smaller ones windows 10 will launch to
the public in 2015 is set to run on
heaps of devices and Microsoft are
implying that it's a huge step up from
people still on Windows 7
bloodborne game director hitter taka
Miyazaki has come out to explain why the
action RPG is not cross generational a
bunch of people have been a tad puzzled
as to why blood-borne is a ps4 exclusive
given the developer from software's
previous games Dark Souls and Dark Souls
2 were playable across multiple
platforms Miyazaki explained that he
needed a console powerful enough to do
justice to the Victorian era setting and
the detail it required he said
blood-borne isn't a game that could have
been cross generational it was only
possible on ps4 finally some clever
destiny players found another mysterious
loot cave not 24 hours after Bungie shut
down the first one ps4 trophies posted a
video of the new loot farming location
at the rocket yard area of old Russia on
earth much like the first location enemy
spawn every six seconds you should it
said baddies until you run out of ammo
then head down to the corpses to grab
more emer and sweet loot while Bungie
haven't shut this one down just yet it's
unlikely to last long since Bungie
already said that shooting at a black
hole for hours isn't exactly the gaming
experience they intended for destiny
players clearly destiny players feel
differently ask your question of the day
let me know what you think of bug
exploits be reckoned as me to fix them
right away or are you a fan this week on
the sides you can see me talk all things
EA on the gist Skyrim mods collides
Tamriel with the god of war and we have
loads of sweet EB Expo coverage that's
all I happy this week thanks for joining
me as always and I will catch you again
on Monday